they arrived in scotland truly the team
like no other ukrainian football players
excused the front line in the pursuit of
sporting success
all ukraine who has this opportunity is
going to wash us and we're gonna feel
this support that's 100
so and like i said already many times
to be fair you know
we can speak a lot but we need to do on
the pitch so that's what we're gonna try
to do
the ukrainian squad came here via
training camp in slovenia in a country
where males their age aren't allowed to
leave domestic players were given a pass
at the start of this month
in the past few days they've been joined
by their big names playing abroad
scots have voiced their support for
ukraine since the russian invasion for
their nation bidding to qualify for a
world cup for the first time in 24 years
tonight it's difficult but it's football
the ukrainians have decided that they
want to play they want to try and give
their country a lift by the football
team performing well they want to go to
the world cup
but it's a game of football we want to
go to the world cup too we've waited a
long time to be in this position the
players our players the scottish players
are desperate to go to qatar 2022.
this is the ukrainian consulate in
edinburgh city centre and this is a
street unofficially named after
ukraine's president there's no doubting
the sympathy in scotland for the plight
of ukraine and its people
whoever wins tonight has a playoff
against wales and cardiff on sunday
there is a lot riding on this game
though everything is relative
james matthews sky news edinburgh